madame la Première ministre vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que l'assassinat
perpétrée contre la professeure
d'espagnol à Saint-Jean-de-Luz a
épouvanté la France entière l'heure est
grave ne craignons pas de nommer la
nature des faits et dont l'extrême
violence ne mérite ni langue de bois ni
au féminisme ni des robes ni cynisme
face à l'ascension fulgurante des
violences intolérables et multiformes
dont son victime les professeurs ainsi
que tous les membres du personnel
éducatif comment prévoyez-vous de réagir
quelle solution concrète et efficace en
matière de prévention et de dissuasion
comptez-vous apporter afin de garantir
enfin la sécurité des enseignants et des
élèves répondre à ces questions est une
nécessité et il en va de notre
responsabilité collective loin de toute
querelle ou récupération partisanes
lorsque vous ouvrez le lévitant de Hobbs
ou le Contrat social de Rousseau il y
ait décrit que la fonction première de
l'État et de garantir la sécurité de ses
concitoyens et il s'agit même de sa
principale raison d'être et le cadre
scolaire ne fait exception à la règle
la minute de silence est certes
symbolique et bienvenue mais la porte
aucun réconfort à la famille de la
victime et ne règle nullement le fond du
problème
l'école et le cœur battant de notre
culture républicaine et doit redevenir
un sanctuaire à l'abri des tumulte du
monde à l'heure où les taux de démission
et des recrutements des professeurs
arrivent à un stade critique où le
rectorat et les ministères préfèrent
parfois courber les Chine devant
certains parfois toujours plus hostiles
et où une logique technique impose des
classes et des programmes surchargés et
les grands temps d'envisager des
nouvelles de réels et de vastes
solutions loin de toute opportunités
par conséquent madame la Première
ministre j'attends avec la plus grande
impatience une réponse de votre part
comme grand nombre de Françaises et de
français lacets et inquiets
[Applaudissements]